Je vous invite à ouvrir vos bibles en 1 chronique, chapitre 29.
On va relire quelques versets du passage qu'on a lu tout à l'heure en base pour notre réunion de prière
et qui sont particulièrement appropriés pour le cours de ce soir sur le thème de l'intendance.
Donc je vais relire ces versets en guise d'introduction à ce cours.
1 chronique, chapitre 29, verset 10.
David bénit l'Éternel en présence de toute l'Assemblée.
Il dit « Béni sois-tu d'éternité en éternité, éternel Dieu de notre Père Israël.
À toi, éternel, la grandeur, la force et la magnificence, l'éternité et la gloire,
car tout ce qui est au ciel et sur la terre t'appartient.
À toi, éternel, le règne, car tu t'élèves souverainement au-dessus de tout.
C'est de toi que viennent la richesse et la gloire, c'est toi qui domines sur tout,
c'est dans ta main que sont la force et la puissance,
et c'est ta main qui a le pouvoir d'agrandir et d'affermir toute chose.
Maintenant, ô notre Dieu, nous te louons et nous célébrons ton nom glorieux.
Car qui suis-je et qui est mon peuple pour que nous puissions te faire volontairement ces offrandes ?
Tout vient de toi et nous recevons de ta main ce que nous t'offrons.
Nous sommes devant toi des étrangers et des habitants,
comme tous nos pères, nos jours sur la terre sont comme l'ombre et il n'y a point d'espérance.
Éternel notre Dieu, c'est de ta main que viennent toutes ces richesses
que nous avons préparées pour te bâtir une maison à toi, à ton saint nom,
et c'est à toi que tout appartient.
Amen.
Seigneur, merci pour ce temps de prière que nous avons déjà pu passer ensemble
et nous te remettons secours sur le sujet important
de l'intendance des biens que tu nous confies,
que ce soit les biens matériels,
notre santé, comme nous le verrons.
Tout ce que nous avons, tout ce que nous sommes,
nous vient de toi
et tu nous appelles à l'utiliser dans un but bien précis
pour ta gloire
et pour nous, chrétiens, pour l'édification de ton Église,
pour bénir
tous nos proches,
notre entourage, Seigneur.
Puisses-tu nous diriger à travers ce cours
et nous permettre de comprendre ces enseignements qui viennent de ta parole
pour que nous puissions apprendre chacun d'entre nous
à mieux gérer les biens que tu nous confieras.
Nous prions cela au nom de Jésus-Christ.
Amen.
Donc bonsoir
et bienvenue
à ce deuxième cours de la série que nous avons commencé la semaine dernière
avec le pasteur Stéphane sur le thème de l'intendance.
L'intendance de nos finances, de nos biens matériels,
que ce soit dans nos vies personnelles
et aussi dans la vie de notre Église.
Donc nous allons continuer cette série
sur l'intendance ce soir avec le deuxième cours.
La semaine dernière,
Stéphane a introduit
cette série
en se basant sur la parabole des talents
que Jésus raconte dans Matthieu,
l'évangile de Matthieu au chapitre 25.
Et il s'est basé sur cette parabole
pour nous expliquer en quoi consiste
déjà notre rôle d'intendant
pour définir ce terme.
Et donc si je peux résumer très rapidement
ce que nous avons vu
la semaine dernière.
Premièrement,
nous avons vu que
tout ce que nous avons,
tout ce que nous possédons,
nous ne le possédons pas en réalité.
Ça ne nous appartient pas,
ça appartient à Dieu.
Tout ce que nous avons,
notre argent,
notre travail,
notre famille,
notre corps,
notre cerveau,
le souffle de vie
que nous avons,
tout cela appartient
en fait à Dieu.
Et donc deuxièmement,
ce qui découle de cette réalité,
c'est que nous ne sommes pas
des propriétaires,
mais des intendants
de toutes ces choses.
Dieu nous les confie
pour que nous les gérions,
que nous en fassions
une bonne gestion.
Nous devons utiliser
tout ce qui nous a été donné
par Dieu
pour un objectif,
pour des objectifs
bien précis
qui ne sont pas déterminés
par nous,
mais par lui.
et donc quels sont
ses objectifs ?
Et c'est ce sujet
qui va nous intéresser
ce soir.
Et je pense que
nous nous trompons,
parfois sans nous en rendre compte,
assez souvent
sur ce sujet,
des objectifs
que Dieu a pour nous
en ce qui concerne
notre intendance.
Ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que
avant de devenir chrétien,
notre vie consistait,
c'est ce que nous pensions,
comme ça que nous avions
l'habitude de fonctionner,
notre vie consistait
à amasser des choses
pour nous-mêmes.
Que ce soit,
comme je l'ai dit,
l'argent,
la réputation,
le succès,
les relations
que nous entretenions,
la célébrité,
toutes ces choses,
nous cherchions
à les accumuler,
à les acquérir
pour nous-mêmes.
Puis,
lorsque nous sommes
devenus chrétiens,
notre vision des choses,
notre mentalité
a changé
et nous sommes dit
d'accord,
j'ai compris,
il ne s'agit plus
de faire
toutes ces choses
pour moi,
il ne s'agit plus
d'accumuler
toutes ces choses
pour moi,
mais pour Dieu.
Et donc,
en fait,
on a gardé
exactement le même,
en se disant ça,
on garde exactement
le même état d'esprit
qu'avant,
mais on oriente
non plus vers nous-mêmes
mais vers Dieu
et nous pensons
qu'en vivant
de cette manière-là,
en cherchant à accumuler
des choses
dans notre vie
pour Dieu,
eh bien,
c'est ça,
vivre comme un chrétien.
Mais en réalité,
comme j'ai dit,
sans parfois
nous en rendre compte,
il y a un problème
avec cette vision
des choses.
Dieu n'a pas besoin
de notre aide.
Au psaume 50,
verset 12,
il est dit,
c'est Dieu qui parle,
« Si j'avais faim,
je ne te le dirai pas,
car le monde est à moi,
ainsi que tout
ce qu'il renferme. »
Dieu n'est pas assis
dans le ciel
à espérer
contre toute attente
que nous allons
nous réveiller
et lui donner
un coup de main
pour gérer
sa création,
pour agir
à sa place.
Non seulement
il est capable
de faire
tout ce que nous,
on peut faire,
mais évidemment,
il est capable
de le faire
et il le fait
bien mieux
que nous.
Et ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'utilise pas
ce que nous faisons,
ça ne veut pas dire
que tout ce que nous faisons
est sans importance,
mais aux yeux de Dieu,
tout cela peut être
important
pour d'autres raisons
que celles auxquelles
nous,
nous pensons habituellement
et instinctivement.
Alors,
si Dieu peut tout faire
sans nous
et mieux que nous,
pourquoi il nous donne
ces choses,
pourquoi il nous confie
tous ses biens
s'il ne dépend pas de nous ?
Quel est son objectif,
quels sont ses objectifs
en ce qui concerne
notre intendance ?
Et pour répondre correctement
à cette question,
nous allons revenir
rapidement
sur la parabole
des talents
en Matthieu 25
et nous allons écouter
attentivement
ce que dit Jésus
dans cette parabole.
Et gardez bien
l'esprit
que le cours d'aujourd'hui
porte sur les objectifs
de Dieu
pour notre gestion
en général.
Notre argent,
certes,
c'est peut-être à ça
qu'on pense en premier,
mais aussi notre temps,
nos emplois,
nos familles,
notre corps,
tous les biens
que Dieu nous a confiés.
Quels sont les objectifs
de Dieu
pour toutes ces choses ?
Donc voici
cette parabole,
comme je le disais,
sur laquelle Stéphane
a enseigné
la semaine dernière.
Vous pouvez l'ouvrir
si vous voulez.
Matthieu,
chapitre 25.
Et donc très rapidement
pour résumer
cette parabole,
un maître,
avant de partir,
confie cinq talents
à un serviteur,
deux talents
à un autre serviteur
et à un troisième,
il confie un talent.
Et puis il s'en va.
Et lorsqu'il revient,
il constate
que les deux premiers serviteurs
ont utilisé ces talents
et ils les ont fait fructifier,
ils en ont gagné d'autres.
Et donc lorsqu'il vient
leur demander des comptes
à son retour,
le résultat
pour le premier serviteur
est bon.
Et le maître lui dit
c'est bien bon
et fidèle serviteur.
Tu as été fidèle
pour peu de choses
et donc je te confierai beaucoup.
Entre dans la joie
de ton maître.
Et même chose
pour le deuxième.
Mais lorsque le troisième serviteur
se présente,
la réponse du maître
est bien différente.
Celui qui avait reçu
ce talent unique
s'avance
et dit à son maître
Seigneur,
je savais que
tu es un homme dur
qui moissonne
où tu n'as pas semé
et qui amasse
où tu n'as pas vanné.
J'ai eu peur
et je suis allé cacher
ton talent dans la terre.
Voici,
prends ce qui est à toi.
Et son maître lui répond
serviteur,
méchant et paresseux,
tu savais que
je moissonne
où je n'ai pas semé
et que j'amasse
où je n'ai pas vanné.
Il te fallait donc
remettre mon argent
au banquier
et à mon retour
je voudrais retirer
ce qui est à moi
avec un intérêt.
Otez-lui donc le talent
et donnez-le
à celui qui a
les dix talents
car on donnera
celui qui a
et il sera dans l'abondance
mais à celui qui n'a pas
on ôtera même
ce qu'il a.
Et le serviteur inutile,
jetez-le dans les ténèbres
au dehors
où il y aura des pleurs
et des grincements
dedans.
Alors comme vous vous en souvenez
peut-être de la semaine dernière,
le dénouement tragique
se situe
à la toute fin
de cette parabole.
Qu'est-ce qui arrive
au troisième serviteur ?
Eh bien,
il va en enfer.
C'est ce que nous dit
le verset 30
dans ce lieu
où il y aura des pleurs
et des grincements
dedans.
C'est une définition
de l'enfer.
Alors on peut se dire
vraiment,
pourtant il n'a pas
perdu le talent,
n'est-ce pas ?
Il l'a rendu au maître
à son retour
et pourtant
il va en enfer.
Parce qu'il n'a pas
rendu plus
que ce qu'on lui avait
confié au départ.
Ça peut nous sembler
au mieux très dur
et même peut-être injuste.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans cette parabole
pour ce troisième serviteur ?
Eh bien,
croyez-vous,
non,
ce qui est en jeu ici
c'est bien
l'évangile.
Et si on retire
l'évangile
de cette parabole,
eh bien,
toute cette parabole
tourne au moralisme.
Ça deviendrait,
le message
de cette parabole
deviendrait
« Faites beaucoup
pour Dieu
et il sera content
de vous
et il vous récompensera. »
Mais si nous pouvons
comprendre pourquoi
les actes
ou plutôt
les non-actes
du troisième serviteur
méritent l'enfer,
alors nous allons
pouvoir voir
cette parabole
avec un œil nouveau.
Et la clé
de compréhension
de cette parabole
réside
dans ce que
les actes
de ce serviteur,
ce troisième serviteur,
disent de son maître,
traduisent
de son maître.
Le troisième serviteur
a en fait essayé
d'avoir le beurre
et l'argent du beurre.
Selon le plan
qui s'était fait
dans sa tête,
tout irait bien
si le maître revenait
parce que,
alors,
il pourrait lui rendre
ce talent
et c'est ce qu'il a fait.
et tout irait bien aussi
si le maître
ne revenait pas
parce qu'il aurait
passé son temps
à vivre pour lui,
à travailler pour lui
et non pas
pour le maître.
En gros,
il s'est mis
à l'abri
pour essayer
de jouer
sur ces deux éventualités.
Et en fait,
le fait de vouloir
jouer sur ces deux éventualités,
que le maître
revienne ou ne revienne pas,
tienne ses promesses
ou non,
ce que ça laissait entendre
comme témoignage extérieur,
c'est que le maître
n'était pas suffisamment
fiable pour tenir
ses promesses.
Ni sa promesse
de revenir,
ni sa promesse
de récompenser
ses serviteurs.
Mais on voit bien
que ce n'est pas le cas,
n'est-ce pas ?
Le maître est revenu
et le maître
était digne de confiance,
donc pour revenir
et aussi incroyablement généreux
pour récompenser
ses serviteurs fidèles.
Et nous le savons,
le maître,
dans cette parabole,
représente Dieu.
Et donc,
lorsque le troisième serviteur
a dit « je savais
que tu es un homme dur »,
en fait,
il a révélé
ce que son attitude
manifestait déjà,
qu'il ne connaissait pas
du tout son maître.
Et ses actions
ont encore plus menti
que ses mots
sur l'excellence
et la fidélité
de ce maître.
Comparé cela
avec la conduite
des deux premiers serviteurs,
eux,
ils ont tout misé
sur les promesses
du maître.
Ils ont parié
leur vie
sur le fait
que le maître
était fidèle
à sa parole,
fidèle
à ses promesses
et que tout risquait
sur cette base-là
des promesses du maître
et pour lui,
c'était la meilleure chose
qu'ils pouvaient faire
pour eux-mêmes.
Et ils ont eu raison,
nous le constatons
à la fin de la parabole.
Donc,
ce rebondissement final
indique
qu'il s'agit bien
d'une parabole
sur la foi.
Il s'agit ici
de faire confiance
au maître
et de rester fidèle
au maître.
Comme Jésus l'a dit
dans son serment
sur la montagne,
personne ne peut servir
deux maîtres.
On ne peut pas avoir
le beurre
et l'argent
du beurre
dans la vie.
On ne peut pas vivre
pour nous-mêmes
et vivre
juste assez pour Dieu
afin de pouvoir
entrer au paradis
aussi.
La double vie
de ce troisième serviteur
montre
qu'il n'avait pas la foi
et c'est ce manque de foi
qui l'a amené
à être infidèle
dans son intendance.
Jacques nous dit
que même les démons
croient en Dieu
et frémissent.
Et quelle est la différence,
on en a parlé dimanche dernier,
entre cette foi démoniaque
et la foi qui sauve ?
La foi salvatrice,
elle ne se contente pas
de croire aux faits
qui concernent Dieu,
comme le font les démons.
Elle croit aussi
que Dieu est bon
envers nous.
La foi salvatrice
croit que les commandements
de Dieu valent la peine
d'être obéis,
que ces récompenses
valent la peine
d'être obtenues.
La foi salvatrice
croit que Dieu
est si bon
que nous pouvons
lui confier
notre vie entière
en laissant tout
derrière nous
si c'est nécessaire.
Et lorsque nous vivons
de cette manière,
nos vies deviennent
des preuves
vivantes
de combien
notre Dieu
est bon
et digne
de confiance.
Mais lorsque nous disons
je veux aller au paradis
mais je veux aussi
couvrir mes arrières
parce que je n'ai pas
vraiment confiance
dans les plans de Dieu
pour moi,
pour cette vie
ou même peut-être
pour cet avenir,
alors nos vies deviennent
à l'inverse
des preuves vivantes
qu'il n'est pas réellement
ou suffisamment bon,
qu'il n'est pas digne
de confiance.
Nous agissons alors
comme ce serviteur
incrédule.
Dans une autre parabole,
celle qu'on appelle
le riche insensé,
vous savez,
ce riche qui construit
des granges
de plus en plus grandes
pour abriter
toutes ses récoltes,
toutes ses richesses
mais qui finit par mourir
de manière soudaine
et qui découvre
évidemment qu'il n'a plus rien
et Dieu traite
cet homme d'insensé
pour cela.
Est-ce que pour cet homme,
les choses auraient été
différentes
s'il avait d'abord
donné 10% à Dieu
par exemple
et ensuite construit
toutes ses granges
plus grandes
pour accumuler
tous ses biens ?
En fait,
ça n'aurait rien changé.
Parce que le problème,
ce n'était pas
dans la façon
dont il avait dépensé
son argent
ou acquis ses biens
mais dans ce que
cette accumulation
disait du caractère
de Dieu.
Son attitude
était en train
de mentir
sur la nature
et le caractère
de Dieu.
Et donc,
quels sont les objectifs
que Dieu a
pour notre intendance ?
Cette parabole,
c'est notre réponse.
Le but de Dieu
à travers notre intendance,
c'est que nous lui
fassions confiance
et que nous soyons fidèles
et qu'à travers cela,
nous rendions un bon témoignage
de son caractère,
de sa nature.
Que notre vie proclame
à quel point Dieu
est parfait,
bon,
digne de confiance
et suffisant pour nous.
Et chaque décision
que nous allons prendre
dira quelque chose
de vrai ou de faux
sur la nature
de notre Dieu.
Et au fur et à mesure
que nous allons grandir
dans la foi,
l'image que notre vie
dépeint de Jésus
va devenir normalement
de plus en plus claire
car selon Romains 8,
verset 29,
Dieu est en train
de nous conformer
à l'image de son Fils.
Et c'est pourquoi
ce sujet est si important.
Et je pense que parfois
nous plaçons ce sujet
de l'intendance
dans la catégorie
de ce qu'on pourrait dire
la bonne éducation
du chrétien.
Si nous voulons
mettre les points
sur les i,
nous allons prendre
un cours sur l'intendance.
Mais les enjeux
sont bien plus importants
et profonds que cela
comme on vient de le voir.
C'est tout l'objet
de cette parabole.
L'intendance,
ça ne consiste pas
à faire la distinction
entre les bons chrétiens
et puis les meilleurs chrétiens.
Il s'agit en réalité
de savoir
si nous avons ou non
la foi qui sauve.
Ce n'est pas une question
de bonne éducation,
c'est une question
de vie ou de mort éternelle
puisque ça concerne
notre salut.
Alors examinons maintenant
cette idée de plus près,
cette idée
de notre fidélité
dans notre intendance
qui proclame
qui est Dieu.
Ce que nous faisons
est important
dans notre vie
parce que cela montre
l'œuvre que Dieu fait en nous,
l'œuvre de restauration,
de sanctification.
L'intendance,
notre intendance,
elle n'est pas tant liée
à ce que nous accomplissons
qu'à ce que cet accomplissement
révèle du caractère de Dieu
aux yeux de ceux
qui nous voient vivre.
C'est exactement
ce que nous voyons
au début de la création
en Genèse 1.
Nous voyons
dans ce chapitre
que notre valeur
en tant qu'être humain
réside dans le fait
que Dieu nous a créés
à son image.
Ça aussi,
on en a parlé
dimanche dernier.
Genèse 1,
verset 27.
Nous représentons Dieu
d'une manière unique
parmi toutes ses créatures.
Notre valeur spéciale
en tant qu'homme,
elle est dite dérivée.
Nous dérivons notre valeur
du fait que nous avons
en nous l'image de Dieu.
Et tout comme les serviteurs
de cette parabole,
notre valeur réside
dans ce que nos choix
disent de notre maître,
disent de notre Dieu.
Il nous a créés
pour être des miroirs vivants,
pour refléter son image
et sa gloire.
Alors,
comment faisons-nous cela ?
On a posé la même question
dimanche dernier,
mais là,
on va répondre
avec une autre facette
de comment nous accomplissons cela,
comment nous reflétons
la gloire
de notre Créateur
dans notre vie.
Et donc,
au verset suivant,
Genèse 1,
verset 28,
nous voyons
que nous faisons cela
parce que nous faisons
dans notre vie.
Dieu dit à l'homme,
soyez féconds,
multipliez,
emplissez la terre
et soumettez-la.
Dominez sur les poissons
de la mer,
sur les oiseaux du ciel,
tout être vivant
qui se meut sur la terre.
Nous représentons Dieu,
nous reflétons l'image de Dieu
à travers nos relations,
comme le mariage.
C'est à travers le mariage
que nous créons la vie
pour remplir la terre,
selon ce que Dieu nous a demandé.
Et nous sommes aussi
l'image de Dieu
par notre travail,
lorsque nous exerçons
par notre travail
cette domination
sur la terre.
mais la clé,
encore une fois,
de compréhension,
c'est que ces choses
n'ont pas d'importance
ou plutôt,
elles n'ont d'importance
que parce qu'elles sont
des moyens
par lesquels
nous reflétons
l'image de Dieu
dans notre vie.
En elles-mêmes,
elles n'ont pas de valeur.
Elles n'ont de valeur
que parce qu'elles sont
des moyens
de refléter Dieu
dans notre vie.
Et tout cela s'exprime,
cette image de Dieu
s'exprime à travers
ce que nous faisons.
Mais ce n'est pas ainsi
que notre monde
voit les choses.
Notre monde, lui,
est à l'inverse
obsédé uniquement
par ce que nous faisons
en tant que tel.
Il nous dit
que nous avons
de la valeur ou non
en fonction de
notre carrière,
notre travail,
nos relations.
Mais le verset 28
de Genèse 1
sans le verset 27
de Genèse 1,
c'est tout simplement
de l'idolâtrie.
Dieu a toujours voulu
que ce que nous fassions
est de la valeur
principalement
parce que cela montre
qui nous sommes
en tant que miroir
de sa gloire.
Et soit dit en passant,
c'est pour cela
que Dieu maudit
en Genèse 3
après le péché
d'Andan et Ève.
Il maudit
nos relations,
il maudit
notre travail.
Pourquoi Dieu
va maudire ces choses
qu'il nous a commandé
de faire au chapitre 1 ?
Il le fait
pour que les relations
seules
ne soient jamais
satisfaisantes,
pour que le travail
seul ne soit
jamais satisfaisant.
Dans sa miséricorde,
Dieu nous empêche
de trouver notre valeur
dans ce que nous faisons
uniquement,
sans tenir compte
de notre valeur
dérivée,
de ce que nous sommes
en tant que porteurs
de son image
à travers
ce travail,
nos relations
et toutes ces autres choses.
après les tristes événements
de Genèse 3,
la chute de l'homme,
les miroirs
de l'image de Dieu
que nous sommes
ont été tordus,
déformés,
fissurés
par le péché.
Mais lorsque nous
devenons chrétiens,
nous devenons
une nouvelle création,
c'est ce que nous dit
la parole.
Donc nous avons été
créés une première fois
à l'image de Dieu
en Genèse 1,
puis nous sommes
recréés,
régénérés,
nous renaissons
à l'image de Dieu
une seconde fois
en tant qu'être humain
racheté.
Et cela signifie
qu'à partir de ce moment
de notre nouvelle naissance,
nous avons à nouveau
l'opportunité
de témoigner
encore plus fort même
de l'excellence
de notre Dieu.
Est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
que c'est la raison principale
pour laquelle Dieu
vous a donné
tout ce que vous avez ?
Pensez à tous les dons
que vous avez reçus
de sa part.
Pour certains d'entre vous,
il peut s'agir
d'un talent musical
ou artistique,
il peut s'agir
d'un don pour les mathématiques,
les langues,
pour d'autres,
il peut s'agir
de leur famille,
de leurs amis,
de l'école,
les études
que vous avez pu faire
ou même
de votre compte en banque
bien rempli,
de votre travail.
1 Corinthiens 4,
verset 7 dit
« Qu'avez-vous
que vous n'ayez pas reçu ? »
Qu'avez-vous
que vous n'ayez reçu ?
Et pourquoi Dieu
vous a-t-il donné
tout cela ?
Il vous a donné
tout cela pour le glorifier.
Pour qu'en utilisant
toutes ces choses,
vous puissiez montrer
à quel point
il est bon
et merveilleux.
Pour que vous puissiez
refléter sa nature,
son caractère
dans votre vie.
Vous avez probablement
ce qu'on appelle
un CV,
un curriculum vitae,
qui résume
votre parcours professionnel,
tous vos accomplissements
dans cette vie.
mais lorsque Dieu
regarde votre vie,
qu'est-ce qu'il constate
comme réalisation ?
Dans chaque acte
d'obéissance fidèle,
il voit ses propres réalisations.
Par notre fidélité,
notre vie devient
le CV de Dieu.
Elle met en évidence
sa bonté,
sa valeur,
sa préciosité.
Et donc,
ce que vous faites
a de l'importance
parce que cela montre
l'œuvre que Dieu
fait en vous.
Alors,
tout cela peut sembler
assez évident,
mais parfois,
ça ne l'est pas.
La plupart d'entre nous,
nous avons l'habitude
d'évaluer notre vie
en fonction des résultats,
de nos résultats,
de ce que nous faisons
plutôt que de la fidélité
et de ce que notre vie
dit de Dieu
par notre fidélité.
Par exemple,
lorsque vous réfléchissez
à votre vie,
de quoi avez-vous
le plus peur ?
Est-ce que vous avez
le plus peur
de l'échec
ou de l'infidélité ?
L'échec vous concerne vous.
Vous ne vivez pas
à la hauteur
de votre potentiel,
de vos attentes,
mais l'infidélité
concerne Dieu.
Vous vivez d'une manière
qui ment
sur ce qu'il est
si vous êtes infidèle,
si vous êtes incrédule.
Et c'est de cela
que nous devrions avoir
le plus peur,
de refléter
une fausse image
de qui est notre Dieu.
Et dans l'économie
de Dieu,
cependant,
notre travail,
notre responsabilité
consiste à être fidèle
et non à obtenir
des résultats.
C'est très important
que ce soit
dans notre vie personnelle,
dans le ministère,
notre vie d'Église.
Ce qui nous concerne,
nous,
c'est la fidélité
et non les résultats.
Parce que la fidélité
montre, encore une fois,
qui Dieu est.
les résultats,
lui,
il peut
et il va
s'en charger lui-même.
Et permettez-moi
d'illustrer cette différence
à l'aide d'un exemple.
Supposons que vous habitiez
en hauteur,
en haut d'une colline
et que vous ne souscriviez pas
à une assurance
contre les inondations.
C'est une décision
plutôt raisonnable.
C'est ce qu'on appellerait
la bonne intendance.
Vous ne gâchez pas
de l'argent inutilement.
C'est très, très peu probable
que vous soyez concerné
par une inondation
à cet endroit-là.
Mais malgré tout,
un jour,
une inondation exceptionnelle
se produit
et submerge
votre maison.
Vous perdez tout.
Vous ne pouvez pas
partir sur le champ missionnaire
à 50 ans
comme vous l'aviez prévu
ou d'autres plans
comme vous les aviez prévus.
Avez-vous échoué ?
Eh bien,
du point de vue des résultats,
on pourrait dire
oui, vous avez échoué.
Vous aviez un objectif,
vous l'avez manqué,
les résultats sont mauvais.
Mais du point de vue
de la fidélité,
non.
Un jour,
vous pourrez vous présenter
devant Dieu,
vous pourrez rendre compte
de votre vie
en bonne conscience,
même si Dieu avait
manifestement d'autres plans
que ceux que vous
vous aviez prévus
au départ.
Un autre exemple,
une femme est médecin
et lorsque elle
et son mari
ont des enfants,
elle réduit son activité
de médecin
pour rester à la maison
s'occuper de ses enfants.
et son mari
l'encourage évidemment
dans cette décision
en lui rappelant
l'importance
de son travail
en tant que mère
au sein du foyer.
Mais les années passent
et puis il discute
un après-midi
et elle pousse un peu
son mari
dans ses retranchements
en lui posant cette question.
Comment changer
des couches
et essuyer des nez
peut-il être plus important
que de sauver des vies
aux urgences ?
Et à ce moment-là,
son mari a réalisé
que toutes les certitudes
qu'il avait
quant à l'importance,
la priorité de la maternité,
elles n'étaient pas basées
sur la bonne chose.
Essuyer le nez
est-il plus important
que de sauver des vies ?
Ce n'est pas la bonne question
à se poser.
Dieu a-t-il vraiment besoin
que nous fassions l'un ou l'autre ?
Se poser cette question,
c'est évaluer nos vies
en fonction des résultats
et non de la fidélité.
Son mari s'est rendu compte
qu'il devrait plutôt
se poser la question
de la fidélité justement
et non des résultats.
Dieu a appelé sa femme
à être une mère.
Comment savoir cela ?
Eh bien,
ils ont eu des enfants.
Voilà comment ils l'ont su.
Mais ils n'ont pas reçu
d'appel divin
sur sa vie
et sa carrière de médecin.
Sa mission première
consiste donc à être fidèle
à sa vocation de mère.
Et dans cette période
particulière de sa vie,
ils ont estimé
que ça signifiait
qu'elle devait
principalement rester
à la maison
avec leurs enfants.
Mais
s'ils disaient
que faire cela,
ils faisaient cela
parce que c'était plus important
que de travailler aux urgences,
imaginez la pression
que ça met
sur leurs pauvres enfants.
Ça revient à dire
à leurs enfants,
votre mère a renoncé
à sauver des vies
pour changer vos couches.
dont vous feriez mieux
de rentabiliser
cet investissement
et d'être
à la hauteur.
Encore une fois,
ça serait réfléchir
par les résultats
et non par
la fidélité.
Mais nous laissons
Dieu décider
de ce qui est
le plus important
dans notre vie
en étant fidèle
à l'appel clair
qu'il a pour nous
à chaque étape
de notre vie.
C'est lui le joueur
d'échec
et nous,
nous sommes simplement
des pièces
de l'échiquier
et nous allons humblement
là où il nous place
avec l'objectif
d'être fidèles
et nous lui laissons
le soin
de décider
des résultats.
De manière générale,
il y a deux problèmes
principaux à vivre
pour les résultats
et basés
sur les résultats.
Premièrement,
nous ne voyons pas
ce qui a vraiment
de la valeur.
C'est souvent difficile
pour nous
d'avoir les idées
claires là-dessus.
Et donc,
c'est une mauvaise base
de jugement.
Prenons deux hommes.
Quelle vie va sembler
la plus précieuse
du point de vue du ciel ?
Un homme qui passe
sa vie à lutter
avec succès
pour la foi en Christ
alors qu'il se débat
avec une maladie mentale ?
De manière extérieure,
aux yeux du monde,
il ne s'épanouit
jamais vraiment.
Il ne conserve jamais
un emploi très longtemps.
Il ne s'investit pas
comme les autres
peuvent le faire
dans la vie
des autres
de son entourage.
et il se contente
quelque part
de survivre
et de tenir bon
jusqu'à la fin.
Et si on compare
cet homme
à un autre
qui dirige
une grande entreprise
philanthropique
qui lutte par la foi
pour rendre gloire
à Dieu
alors que son organisation
prospère,
son entreprise prospère,
comment savoir
ce qui a le plus
de valeur
dans cette vie
du point de vue céleste ?
Mais ce n'est pas
notre travail
de le savoir.
Notre travail
consiste à obéir
fidèlement
dans toutes les situations
où Dieu nous place
avec ce qu'il nous donne.
Mais il y a aussi
un deuxième problème
à vivre
pour les résultats
et basé sur les résultats.
Si nous mesurons
le succès
en fonction
de la valeur
de ce que nous faisons,
alors nous ne pouvons
être que déçus
à la fin.
Proverbe 23,
verset 4 à 5
nous dit
« Ne te tourmente pas
pour t'enrichir,
n'y applique pas
ton intelligence.
Veux-tu poursuivre
du regard
ce qui va disparaître ?
Car la richesse
se fait des ailes
et comme l'aigle,
elle prend son vol
vers les cieux. »
Si vous êtes médecin,
tous ceux
que vous sauverez,
que vous soignerez,
finiront un jour
par mourir.
Tous les ponts
que vous allez concevoir
et construire
en tant qu'ingénieur
finiront par s'écrouler.
La plupart des choses
que vous enseignez,
vos enfants vont les oublier.
La plupart de ce que
vous écrivez,
personne ne va jamais
le lire.
La ville de Paris
est remplie
de monuments magnifiques
à la gloire
de personnes importantes
dont vous n'avez
jamais entendu parler
et que tout le monde
a oublié.
La mauvaise nouvelle,
c'est que les résultats
ne durent pas.
Mais la fidélité,
elle,
elle dure
parce que l'obéissance
fidèle
met en évidence
la gloire
et la bonté
de Dieu
qui,
elles,
dureront
pour toujours.
Alors,
bien sûr,
nous devons nuancer
un peu cela
et être prudents
lorsque nous opposons
les résultats
à la fidélité
comme on vient
de le faire
de manière
assez catégorique
ici,
car bien souvent
ce sont les résultats
qui nous aident
à voir
si nous sommes
en réalité fidèles.
si vous êtes
missionnaire
dans un pays
très fermé
et que dix ans
passent
depuis que vous y êtes
sans que vous ne voyez
un seul converti,
il est possible
que vous ayez été fidèle,
un intendant fidèle
dans cette mission
que Dieu vous a donnée,
mais il est aussi possible,
voire probable,
que vous n'obteniez
pas de résultats
parce que vous n'êtes
pas un bon missionnaire.
si vous investissez
l'argent que Dieu
vous a donné en bourse
et qu'il perd
la moitié de sa valeur,
il est possible
que vous ayez été fidèle
et que vous ayez
rencontré une situation
vraiment imprévue,
mais il est également
possible que vous ayez
mal investi
et que vous n'auriez
pas dû vous fier
à votre mauvaise analyse.
En fin de compte,
à travers ces exemples,
nous voyons que ce ne sont
pas les résultats
qui nous intéressent,
mais bien le fait
que Dieu nous compte
parmi les fidèles
au dernier jour.
N'oubliez pas
que Dieu ne dépend pas
de nous.
Il ne dépend pas de nous
pour faire passer
des lois dans notre pays
ou pour élever
des enfants
ou pour financer
des missionnaires
ou pour donner
des conseils
ou pour nourrir
les affamés.
Il est un meilleur dirigeant,
un meilleur père,
un meilleur évangéliste,
un meilleur conseiller,
un meilleur pourvoyeur
que vous et moi
ne pourrons jamais l'être.
Mais ce travail,
ces enfants,
ce missionnaire,
ce problème à régler
et cette personne
dans le besoin
sont autant d'occasions
pour nous
de montrer l'œuvre
que Dieu a accomplie
et continue d'accomplir
en nous.
Pour citer ce verset
bien connu
d'un Corinthien
10, verset 31,
un verset qui résume
un peu tout
ce que nous venons
de dire ici,
que vous mangez,
que vous buviez
ou que vous fassiez
quoi que ce soit,
faites tout
pour la gloire de Dieu.
Faites tout
ce qu'il vous appellera
à faire fidèlement
pour manifester
sa bonté.
Voilà en résumé
la raison
pour laquelle
la fidélité
est importante.
Mais à quoi
ressemble
concrètement
cette fidélité
dans notre vie ?
Et permettez-moi
de vous donner
deux catégories
à garder à l'esprit
à ce sujet.
Premièrement,
la fidélité
en tant qu'obéissance.
Parfois,
la fidélité,
souvent même,
elle consiste
simplement
à obéir
à un ordre
clair de Dieu.
Encore un exemple,
je veux vraiment
obtenir une promotion
à mon travail.
Et il devient évident
que je pourrais
arriver à obtenir
cette promotion
à la fin de l'année
si je masquais
un peu
la réalité
et la vérité
lors d'une vente
que je dois faire.
Mais je choisis
de ne pas faire cela
pour obéir
à la volonté
claire de Dieu
et je dis la vérité
et donc je ne reçois
pas cette promotion.
Et donc,
je suis félicité
au dernier jour
par Dieu
lorsque je me tiens
devant lui
parce que j'ai été
fidèle à ce moment-là.
Même si je ne pourrais
pas être aussi généreux
avec l'argent
que j'aurais eu en plus
dans cette vie
si j'avais été promu
en mentant.
L'obéissance
dans tous
les domaines
illustre l'Évangile
est témoin
du caractère
du Dieu
que nous servons.
Par exemple,
lorsque nous remercions
Dieu
pour ce que nous avons
reçu,
nous glorifions Dieu
qui donne
toutes les bonnes choses
selon Éphésiens 5
verset 19.
Lorsque nous rendons
les prémices,
nos offrandes,
nous glorifions Dieu
comme étant dignes
de confiance
parce que nous savons
qu'il va pourvoir.
Matthieu 6
verset 33.
Lorsque nous sommes
satisfaits
de notre niveau
de richesse
que nous vivons
dans le contentement,
nous glorifions Dieu
comme étant suffisant
pour répondre
à nos besoins,
à nos attentes.
Et lorsque nous utilisons
nos richesses
de manière sacrificielle,
généreuse
pour aider les autres
autour de nous,
nous glorifions Dieu
comme étant plein
d'amour
et de miséricorde
envers nous.
Mais comme nous le constatons
souvent,
les choses ne sont pas
aussi claires
que nous les soutenions
comme cet exemple
de l'homme
qui a le choix
entre mentir
ou dire la vérité.
Après tout,
dans la parabole
de Jésus
en Matthieu 25,
le maître n'a jamais
dit à ses serviteurs
ce qu'il devait faire
avec l'argent
qu'il leur a confié.
Et Dieu est glorifié
lorsque nous recherchons
ce qui a de la valeur
à ses yeux
dans son économie,
même si ce monde
voit les choses
de manière très différente.
Cela signifie
qu'en tant que chrétiens,
nous devons
quelque part
devenir des experts
en comparaison
de prix.
Chaque fois
que nous consacrons
du temps
ou de l'argent
à quelque chose,
il y a toujours
un manque
à gagner ailleurs.
Nous aurions pu
investir dans quelque chose
d'autre
pour un but différent.
Et certaines choses
valent plus que d'autres
aux yeux de Dieu.
Et donc,
si nous voulons être
des intendants fidèles,
nous devons prendre
au sérieux
cette comparaison.
Parfois,
il s'agit de comparer
des choses
qui ont une valeur matérielle.
est-ce que je dois
payer un plombier
pour réparer mon évier
et profiter de ce temps
que je vais gagner
pour aller à l'étude biblique ?
Ou est-ce que je dois
réparer l'évier moi-même
et faire don
à l'église
de l'argent
que j'ai économisé
en réparant moi-même ?
Dans chaque transaction
de la vie,
qu'il s'agisse
de déterminer
si je vais faire
de l'exercice
le matin,
si je dois acheter
un soda à midi
ou quel emploi
je vais occuper,
dans toutes ces transactions,
je peux choisir
l'option
qui a le plus de valeur
aux yeux de Dieu.
Parfois,
ça implique
d'investir
dans des biens
qui sont non matériels,
des biens intangibles.
Si nous revenons
aux proverbes,
nous voyons
beaucoup de comparaisons
de ce type-là.
Par exemple,
la sagesse
est plus précieuse
que le rubis,
la crainte de Dieu
est plus importante
que les grandes richesses
matérielles,
la justice
est plus importante
que l'argent
et une bonne réputation
est plus importante
que de grandes richesses
encore.
Ailleurs,
nous voyons
que notre foi en Dieu
est plus importante
que l'or
et que le salut
de notre âme
vaut mieux
que de gagner
le monde entier.
Et parfois,
cela implique
d'investir
dans ce qui n'a
de valeur
qu'à la lumière
de l'éternité.
S'il est vrai
qu'on ne peut pas
emporter ce qu'on a acquis
avec nous
dans notre tombe,
nous pouvons envoyer
des biens,
des richesses
à l'avance
qui nous devancent
dans l'éternité.
Que feriez-vous
si vous voyez
aux informations
que dans dix jours,
nous allons abandonner
l'euro
et nous allons commencer
à utiliser le yén ?
Eh bien,
vous allez convertir
tout ce que vous avez
en monnaie chinoise,
n'est-ce pas ?
Vous allez abandonner
tout ce qui est
sur le point
de perdre de la valeur
et vous allez investir
dans ce qui va conserver
de la valeur.
Et Jésus nous dit
que c'est exactement
ce qui va arriver
lorsque nous allons passer
de cette vie
à la suivante.
Voici ce qu'il dit.
« Ne vous amassez pas
des trésors sur la terre
où la teigne
et la rouille
détruisent
et où les voleurs
percèrent des robes
mais amassez-vous
des trésors dans le ciel
où la teigne
et la rouille
ne détruisent pas
et où les voleurs
ne percèrent
et ne dérobent pas
car là où est votre trésor
là aussi
sera votre cœur.
Un jour viendra
où chaque euro
que vous possédez
n'aura plus aucune valeur
pour vous
soit parce que vous serez morts
soit parce que Jésus
sera revenu.
Mais vous avez la possibilité
dès aujourd'hui
d'utiliser cet argent
pour investir
dans un trésor éternel
qui lui
ne va jamais perdre
de la valeur
et ne va jamais disparaître.
Et il en va de même
pour votre temps,
pour vos compétences,
votre énergie,
vos relations
et tous les dons
que Dieu vous accorde.
Vous pouvez dès aujourd'hui
les mettre à profit
en vue de l'éternité.
L'argent ne peut pas
acheter le salut.
Il ne peut même pas
acheter la foi.
l'espérance
ou l'amour.
Mais par contre,
il peut certainement
être utilisé
pour construire
ces choses
et les exercer
dans notre vie.
C'est ce qu'a compris
la veuve de Marc 12,
verset 41,
lorsqu'elle a donné
tout ce qu'elle possédait,
ses deux petits deniers,
pour...
Elle a donné ça
en offrande au temple.
Elle a utilisé son argent
pour grandir dans sa foi
en Dieu,
pour lui rendre gloire.
Ainsi,
lorsque vous prêtez
un ami
qui est dans le besoin,
même si vous ne savez pas
s'il va vous rembourser
un jour,
eh bien,
vous utilisez votre argent
pour faire grandir
votre foi
et mettre de l'ordre
dans vos priorités
dans votre vie.
Lorsque vous utilisez
votre voiture
pour conduire quelqu'un
à l'église,
vous utilisez votre argent,
vos biens,
pour l'aider à être instruit
par la parole de Dieu.
et dans l'économie de Dieu,
tout cela constitue
des transactions
qui sont judicieuses
à faire.
Pour conclure,
tout comme les intendants fidèles
décrits dans la parabole,
nous sommes appelés
à mettre tous nos œufs
dans le même panier,
à tout miser
sur la même table.
S'il s'avérait
que les promesses de Dieu
n'étaient pas vraies,
alors quelqu'un pourrait
examiner notre budget,
notre emploi du temps
et il dirait
c'est un désastre,
ils ont tout misé
sur les promesses de Dieu.
Mais j'espère bien,
frères et sœurs,
que nous allons tout miser
sur les promesses de Dieu,
que nous allons vivre
pour être fidèles
afin que notre vie
témoigne de la bonté
de notre Dieu
et de tous ses autres attributs.
Et bien sûr,
la meilleure
de toutes les nouvelles,
c'est que Jésus
va produire cette fidélité
en nous.
Il a versé son sang
pour nous racheter,
il nous a marqués
de son nom.
Avant même
la fondation du monde,
il nous a prédestinés
à être
des portraits magnifiques
de son amour
et de sa miséricorde.
Et il va passer
notre vie
à peindre ce portrait
et une éternité
à l'exposer
aux yeux
de toute la création.
Romains 8,
verset 29,
car ceux
qu'il a connus d'avance,
il les a aussi
prédestinés
à être conformes
à l'image
de son Fils.
Et pensez-vous
qu'avec tout
ce qui est en jeu
que nous venons d'énumérer,
Dieu va laisser quelqu'un,
vous en particulier,
tout gâcher.
Si vous êtes chrétien,
vous allez échouer
dans cette vie
à certains moments.
Vous allez
pécher,
vous allez lutter
contre le péché,
mais vous aurez aussi
la foi.
Vous allez obéir,
vous allez persévérer.
Et à chaque minute
de tout ce cheminement complexe,
Dieu peint en nous
son image
pour sa gloire éternelle.
Et c'est
pour cet objectif
que nous devons
faire une bonne intendance
de tous les biens
qu'il nous confie.
Amen.